the energy of atlanta is incredibly
interesting and i think it's different
than anywhere in the nation
the idea of mixing southern hospitality
with
kind of an old-school southern flair
with a lot of new energy
pop culture the colleges the amount of
black businesses that
are here millennial strives for black
excellence there's a great energy about
the city
i can identify with the legacy and the
history of civil rights
this was the backyard of some of the
greatest civil rights leaders of all
times the sclc being founded in atlanta
the history of black leadership mayna
jackson and andrew young and dr
king all of them started here
really put atlanta on a world map
[Music]
when nike came on board with the nba and
created a city
edition platform it was kind of a
revolutionary idea to like have a jersey
that
ties to the city and is expressive and
allows for teams to tell community
stories in impactful ways
my very first year was trying to
distinguish what the city edition would
be
for this season so it's been about a
three year long process
the idea of partnering with the king of
state was an early idea that i had
when the hawks approached us about the
mlk city edition uniform concept we were
very intrigued
whenever we have an opportunity we try
to move dr
king from the history books and into the
lives of younger generations
and so sitting down with the nike team
they embraced it we actually had a team
member who
traveled out to atlanta to visit with
the team and got a lot of pictures and
inspiration
went to ebenezer baptist church and went
to the king center
when he brought it all that back it was
just really inspiring
in partnership with the king of state
and developing this entire idea they
were so excited
there was no hesitation at all linking
dr king's legacy to sports
we realized the power of sports and the
medium that it is
so we thought it made perfect sense to
partner with the hawks on this honoring
dr king
is a natural connection for us we knew
that like this is more than just a
jersey it means so much more to us
each element of the design of the
uniform has a specific meaning and
intent
it was well thought out in that way
there are a number of elements to the
uniform that really speaks to dr king
obviously the black and gold as a nod to
his fraternity alpha phi alpha
the side panel on the shorts we had to
end that arch to kind of harken back to
church window panes the stars represent
the student freedom fighters that were a
part of the movement the word mark
obviously reading mlk
that's never been done before a person's
initials being dawned on the jersey
all of it comes together to really
represent what this uniform means to the
city of atlanta
i had a chance to get a sneak peek at
him it's just it's purifier i'm getting
texts and
calls that people are going to go get it
the nba definitely seems to be the
league that's leading the encouragement
of athlete activism
continue to uplift all the other
athletes that let them know that they
can
say and do what's right we won't be
silent
enough is enough to wear those three
letters across our chest
it's got to mean something to you i got
to play just a little bit harder when i
have that jersey on
this is not just a new uniform it is a
commitment we can continue to have those
conversations about what dr kane's
legacy
truly means and what we can do to play
our part in addressing the efforts
moving forward
i try to carry out his legacy and his
messages i look at everybody as an
individual
it's not the color of your skin it's to
contact your character it's so important
to keep educating ourselves
about the importance of equality
that message will never get old i don't
know if there's
another way that you can represent the
city of atlanta better than representing
through dr martin luther king
we want this uniform to really be
something historic that people hold on
to and really take pride in for years to
come but we want to make sure that we
continue this conversation and that
people don't just talk about it they do
the work
and earning these letters for us means
exactly that
[Music]